so in the mid-1980s a philosopher and
theologian by the name of dr james carse
articulated these two types of games
finite games and infinite games a finite
game is defined as known players
fixed rules and an agreed upon objective
football baseball
if there's a winner necessarily there
have to be losers and there's always a
beginning middle and an end right then
you have infinite games infinite games
are defined as known and unknown players
which means you don't necessarily know
who all the players are and new players
can join whenever they want
um
the rules are changeable which means
every player can play however they want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible
turns out where we're players in
infinite games every day of our lives
right there's no such thing as um
winning global politics there's no such
thing as winning marriage you can't be
number one in your marriage you can be
number two but you can't be number one
right
um
uh there's no such thing as winning
education
nobody wins learning
you can come in first for the finite
amount of time you're at school where
you agree upon the time frame and the uh
uh and the metrics grades but nobody
wins education and nobody wins business
like when circuit city went bankrupt
best buy didn't win anything
right
but if you listen to the language of so
many leaders half the room doesn't know
what circuit city is i know it's sort of
i realized
it used to be a company that competed
with best buy same thing
big buck store went in bought a vcr you
don't know what a vcr is
um
what i love about this these definitions
is that when we listen to the language
of so many leaders
it becomes abundantly clear that they
don't know the game they're playing in
the number of leaders who talk about
being number one being the best or
beating their competition
based on what
based upon what agreed upon metrics time
frames or objectives and this is a
problem because when we play with a
finite mindset in an infinite game when
we play to win in a game that has no
finish line there's some consistent and
predictable outcomes the big ones are
the decline of trust the decline of
cooperation and the decline of
innovation so
let's translate that to a policing
organization right
an infinite game is not the absence of
finite games it is the context within
which finite games exist clearly you are
engaged in finite things every day of
your career you have a project that you
need to complete there's a beginning
middle and end if someone has committed
a crime you want to try and catch that
person there is a known objective
there's a beginning middle and end
there's going to be a winner there's
going to be a loser right if somebody
you're chasing somebody down for for a
moving violation for example this is
these things are finite
but policing and the organization of the
orange county sheriff is an infinite
organization
we hope that this organization outlasts
everybody here and thrives beyond
everybody here so the decisions we make
and the way we conduct ourselves have to
be considerate of the fact that we want
this organization to thrive for the long
term